moi se parler franchement
on va se parler franchement qu'ils
emmerdent l'avis de qui aujourd'hui qui
gâchent la vie de nos soignants qui
depuis deux ans sont mobilisés sous
l'eau dans nos services de réanimation
pour sauver des patients qui aujourd'hui
sont essentiellement non vaccinés ce
sont ceux qui s'opposent au vaccin qui
gâchent la vie de nos commerçants de nos
restaurateurs de nos théâtres de nos
cinémas qui depuis deux ans vivent avec
une épée de damoclès au-dessus de la
tête quand ils n'ont pas été fermées ce
sont ceux qui s'opposent au vaccin qui
gâchent la vie de nos personnes âgées
qui sont contraintes de vivre dans la
solitude dans la peur dans la peur face
à une épidémie ce sont ceux qui
s'opposent au vaccin alors moi je vais
vous dire les choses nous avons toujours
dit les choses extrêmement clairement et
nous continuerons à les dire clairement
et je vais vous dire que les propos du
président de la république me semble
très en-deça de la colère d'une très
grande majorité des français face à ce
choix qui est fait de s'opposer aux
accents vous discutez avec des français
aujourd'hui je sens avait beaucoup qui
vous disent mais les personnes qui font
le choix de ne pas se faire vacciner on
ne devrait même pas les soigner nous
nous avons toujours fait le choix avec
nos soignants de soigner tous les
français qui étaient frappées par la
maladie et nous continuerons à faire ce
choix c'est un choix en responsabilité
mais la responsabilité c'est aussi de
prendre les mesures nécessaires pour
protéger tous les français et parfois
pour protéger certains français y
compris contre eux mêmes et nous allons
continuer à assumer aussi cette
responsabilité comme l'a dit le
président de la république ce matin on
agit on explique et on assume
[Musique]